le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
trouver un emploi ou une formation sur
l'île n'est pas toujours évident c'est
pourquoi certains jeunes choisissent la
mobilité en métropole ou à l'étranger
pour les soutenir
le cna remet le comité national
d'accueil et d'actions pour les
réunionnais en mobilité propose d aide
et un accompagnement aux jeunes
réunionnais l'uci est en contrat de
professionnalisation sur marseille kevin
vient d'achever deux ans d'apprentissage
sur paris ils ont tous les deux
bénéficié du soutien du cnls armes
[Musique]
à 20 ans lucie est en apprentissage mais
aujourd'hui pas question pour elle de
travailler
la jeune réunionnaise est en vacances et
profite de son retour aux sources
j'habite à marseille 600 managers
j'ai surtout par le cnam qui est en fait
les jeunes de la réunion puis trouver du
travail
c'est avec l'aide du comité d'accueil et
d'actions pour les réunionnais en
mobilité que l'uci a pu mener à bien son
projet il y a deux ans donc non m'a payé
mon billet d'avion aller ils ont trouvé
l'école pour moi ensuite si on donnait
pas mal de pistes pour que je puisse
postuler en alternance une fois à
marseille
l'institution a accompagné la jeune
réunionnaise dans son installation
pendant deux mois j'ai eu 18 ans et
j'habite dans un appartement en fait
prévu que martin veut jouer pour mon
pack on a trouvé notre attente à nous
installer
je pense que ça aurait été beaucoup plus
difficile sans sable quand on arrive en
métropole et que
personnes entre guillemets c'est bien
d'avoir un logement et le cnam
privilégie le lien avec les entreprises
via des formations en alternance
lucie elle est en contrat de
professionnalisation
j'ai deux jours de cours et trois jours
d'entreprise en touche 80 % du sud en
fait le nom on doit leur envoyer tous
les mois la fiche de paie
elles ne comprennent plus cosmique c'est
la première fois que la jeune
réunionnaise rentrer sur l'île
elle a bénéficié d' aide pour l'achat de
son billet au bout d'un an de travail
consécutifs il nous donne 700 euros afin
qu'on puisse payer deux billets d'avion
en fait notre site
lucie s'envolera bientôt pour poursuivre
son aventure en métropole
kevin lui est de retour sur l'île après
deux ans d'apprentissage
lui aussi a bénéficié du soutien du cnls
armes j'ai connu le tarn par les
affiches publicitaires suite à ça je
suis allé sur le site internet où j'ai
pris
leurs coordonnées j'ai pris un
rendez-vous le conseiller marc ensuite
orienté vers la formation qui me
plaisait et ensuite ça s'est fait très
vite
en l'espace de quelques mois pris
l'avion pour partir et sap aventure
sympa
était en contrat d'apprentissage pendant
deux ans je préparais à 1 dts management
des unités commerciales de travailler
dans une épicerie s'appelait cos dans
une alimentation générale du tanit et
kevin est revenu il ya un an avec
l'intention cette fois de s'installer
définitivement
il est aujourd'hui chargé de
développement commercial pour une
entreprise locale m'a permis de partir
pour me former pour revenir à la réunion
plus qualifiés d' entamer
professionnels et paris si je devais
faire passer un message aux réunionnais
qui hésitent à partir métropole ça
serait de pas hésiter c'est une belle
aventure
on apprend beaucoup et surtout pas pour
mieux revenir
soutenue par le conseil départemental le
kn armes est un acteur stratégique pour
l'emploi mobilité des réunionnais en
métropole et à l'étranger les
réunionnais qui ne trouvent pas de
l'emploi ou formation adéquats ici à la
réunion font aujourd'hui plus facilement
le choix de la mobilité
ils le peuvent aller se former ou en
métropole formation en contrat
d'alternance en contrat d'apprentissage
et des parle notre opérateur lucknow
et puis la mobilité ça n'est pas
seulement aller en métropole ou en
europe
la mobilité de ce fait dans la zone
océan indien il ya aujourd'hui beaucoup
de réunionnais qui sont installés ou à
madagascar ou aux seychelles
à travers donc des contrats de
d'éducateur en langue française depuis
des nombreuses années voire même en inde
et en afrique
ils sont nombreux à faire le choix de la
mobilité dans la zone océan indien
[Musique]
cofinancé par le département et l'europe
le cnam a pour mission de préparer à la
mobilité et accompagner les jeunes
réunionnais à la recherche d'emploi en
métropole ou à l'étranger
il propose entre autres la prise en
charge du billet d'avion aller et retour
une allocation d'arrivée de 300 euros
une aide à l'hébergement et une
indemnité allant de 600 à 1200 euros
une indemnité complémentaire équivalent
à 95 % du smic pour les contrats en
alternance
les personnes éligibles aux aides du
cnls armes doivent être âgés de 18 ans
et être demandeur d'emploi à la réunion
mayotte et être en situation régulière
et en capacité légale sur le territoire
français et européen en 2015 2012
placement en emploi ont été recensés
actuellement le cna remet à 1404 offres
à pourvoir pour consulter ces offres ou
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet
www.caf.fr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m